gentlemen members offices this is the
development committee not District
Council I have some initial absolutely
go through so that we wear this debate
first of all the emergency evacuation
Wilson should we be required to evacuate
the building would you please leave the
building by the nearest available access
to the China assembly point will be in
the car park public art but other side
of acidic sweet please do not delay your
evacuation to collect any problems
please do not return the building until
given permission to do so by council so
please note that this meeting will be
audio recorded and I think we'd be
grateful if you would put any mobile
phones either turn off or two beers
please
it was a very description of this
weekend those are the public revised
this is an official council meeting and
the item before us will be feted the
cording through usual council rules that
apply to council meetings to which the
public are committed midges members of
the public are not permitted to sleep in
this meeting unless they have previously
registered to speak with men the
services in this way everyone presently
under here is bait the council's will be
able to make your decision I have
apologies from Council of black this
substituted by castleton capsule
discipline so substituted by health of
the woman councillor Smith who is
substituted by council mrs. sensor and
counsel award is substituted by
counselor mrs. Williams
well as we have come to norman is
attending i have counselors library
studying capsules uses a mystery which
is for it Oh cats little quiet
right there come to the minutes of the
meeting held on twenty first of January
2016 dude when is free that I can sorry
nose is correct please do thank you
writes some declarations of interest
fees just very
Thank You German I have a display
disposable impact by a disposable
universe Hughes conscience is my home to
the subject site and I should be linked
the table during discussion notes
application which would solid leads
please I'm sorry Leslie this one much I
don't like they've got a big ability
like this happen there's a little bit is
not a non performing an opportunity
interesting on all sides by check out in
items of fish my ipad for class shoes
thank you guess later Peggy mr. Chairman
I have mr. Clarion on to fury in prayer
sign of attend Victoria Road and shall
not be affected by direct illumination
those issues but by potential hardly
high road I have received advice from a
legal department that it is proper for
me to sit I shall approach this and then
anybody thank you there's such a
sensible I have no interest is on the
townhouse don't do not sit on the
Planning Committee of Turkish thank you
right we have the generating but six has
been removed they've drawn from the
agenda is equal to meeting which did
resolve some of your changes I've also
moved your we are certainly many
students we're also the item result
apply castle to be first on our list
nobody's majority of here for in the
public interest weakness is trying to
present instance my nature Kevin if I
might even be
chairman disaggregation basically this
one's your safety in the cursor on the
eastern side of the road I feel the
concerns of tonight at the rear and it's
also a short distance ready town center
which you can't see on that in Egypt
further to the to the south to them to
the right of your screen you can see
from the aerial photograph that we have
here at the site adjoins or has backing
onto residential properties of all the
three on all three sides a period a
footpath links to the southern side
between hockley road and having the road
and to the east there are two trees on
the site here the subject to a tree
preservation order for the application
before you tonight chairman is to
propose a artificial surface or whether
football with rugby copy sort of playing
fields for higher pitch footage is the
images I find faith that the main school
building is down here and the boundaries
we will come out on the aerial
photograph for approximately
feel like this is the two trees i
mentioned that the subject of the
preservation the peach would be enclosed
which we'll see in medical innovation by
offense these for a half meters high the
mesh design green mesh design with three
meter high Coast boarding fencing to the
lower portion the pitch would be flooded
by 8 15 meter high Cotton's that you see
a side elevation so the other four be
lopsided if you fire and would be used
by the school and its partners
particularly yourseif anandpur chairman
that the use would include weekends and
outside school hours applicants of
suggesting of our offices you'll see in
the recommendation secret a slight
change for that the applicants would
wish for hours between 8am and 10pm
between mondays and fridays an 8am to
pay to being on saturdays sundays and
bank colleges members will see from the
report for the provision of additional
pitches and the wider use of education
facilities but cubs outside school hours
is generally encouraged by council
planning policy subject type of material
considerations such as the effect on
residential immunity
the proposed pitch would be located
behind the main school building a coup
stick report the company in the
application concludes of the predicted
noise level below that from what
relationship outside of the units such
as gardens who but also seeing that an
application on astroturf multi-day
Jazeera was allowed on this site on of
people here over 20 years ago this was
never implemented if I they recommend
the later start and for some reason back
at 9am upon my raised earlier birds was
also received a report that the external
variety would be similarly controlled by
it to acceptable levels by the same
hours condition and that a further
condition is also recommended one way of
controlling or requiring a planning
application for any and provide speech
or news existence against the wider use
of the existing pitches without the
quality fresh commissioned officers
consider the impact of and residential
immunity advising proposal favors the
grants of Planning Commission those that
visually means the proposal would be
visible particular from upper floor
windows the neighboring properties and
to help members the pitch is for doing
this siddity here on the site in the
middle path if you line up from the two
trees and the back of innings here but
it's against the backdrop of the
slightest all main buildings which are
up to four stories high in one
particular place on people in that
chairman and even backdrop and the
presence of the larger buildings up
not think visually such as it would be
saved we'd be so officially damaging to
help you against the proposal and visual
means events in terms of party members
will realize there is a large I think
Homer Homer an area to the front of the
site plus two other car parks the sudden
decide which total some 120 offering car
parking spaces the seat from the report
chairman that the car parking standard
is adopted by the council requires a
maximum of 20 or 30 sees for this
facility and obviously if you allow for
perhaps possible other classes being
held at school at the same time also out
of ours and the proximity that turns
into car parking officers and county
highway authority conclude that there is
sufficient car parking in the site
acidity and end on the site to support
the use in terms of drainage issues
raised members were safer the report
that these concerns have been raised
with the county council sustainable
drainage thing and they could consider
both the application or so the flood
risk assessments and knitted with the
application and you'll see that in
conclusion members can see that there is
no objection raised to the proposal
subject to condition to recommendation
which requires the provision of a they
only area and precise details how you
agreed because of the dire to prevent
those works harming needs us entry cover
to the site boundaries so making the
precise details of that to get them away
from the trees and the harm the
excavation otherwise cause she's left as
an extra condition in addition to the
letters set out on the
our repulsion we have received two
further one since we've written report
well at which I email which is an
address if they read it to you looking
at the change in the weather in the
north of the country and all of the
slapping those happening and you really
look at the proposal for the changes to
fix why mark to include multiple pitch
that will increase the risk of local
flooding due to the runoff of water
being increased in the local area it
does appear a little strange that the
decision is taken some three to four
months we decided on I realize that
procedures have to be followed but this
does not have the locals who can suffer
reductions of property values and the
additional traffic problems that i am
going to take issue with it DCC we've
not comply with certain legal
requirement regarding rose as well as
our PC as an accomplice and set the one
chain from the address of seven ruffles
Croson raley my comments our regards to
the construction of 3g each the boundary
got my garden so house will be less than
a hundred yards away from this
development so I feel my quality of life
should be considered I'm not against the
facility it's good to the school and
pupils during school times I am totally
against this facility being used up to
10 p.m. weekdays or p.m. on weekends the
light pollution at night and the noise
pollution will considerably effective
quality of life as I go into there is my
professional career requires me to do so
The Associated bag language that comes
with unregulated you thoughtful towards
extremely unpleasant to hear I was
trying to relax in my god the general
prevailing wing will amplify that noise
and will bring extra amounts of unwanted
rubbish and litter into my garden I
really have to pick up empty sweet and
crisp packets and school is this is just
increase this is solely in my eyes a
commercial
surprise and should be treated as such
based on the proposals if it was just
about providing better pitches for the
pupils and far cheaper option is to add
pipe drainage and to have the sports
pitching better maintained by a regular
30 draining I am a golf course manager
and another everything there is to know
about sports stuff and now that would be
a far cheaper option the effect on the
quality of life of nearby residents by
such a facility used outside normal
school hours as a commercial enterprise
should not impact on the quality of life
for local residents chairman problem the
report that you see before you you'll
see that accordingly officers recommend
mission be granted subject to the
conditions set out and remove they use
Stokes they have listed three seekers
also see a non-member and also
interesting firstly can we cápsulas is
the Mercer of Grady town council can do
in terms of oxbow you will have the five
minutes from
thank you I am live immerse our chairman
Pro 10 pounds and he can see and hear to
their objections on behalf of the town
council fits four months for a
significant application with 3g
artificial turf pitch refocusing and
artificial lighting to be used seven
times a week at times ranging money to
Friday 8am to 10pm and said via Sunday
8am General Motors has changed you know
England condition nine I in jun 2015 the
town council plan committee objected to
the plans of the grams of excessive
light pollution and noise the residence
due to these opening end and the
majority of the committee also voted
people flooding issues in our objection
I may be friends came to take out the
October 2015 but objected to a game
since they had not addressed the
concerns that we have had in their
zoning application many residents has
voiced concerns over the issue there are
children as well as Ethel's some Emily
who will be served by the noise of hers
and supported calling out during the day
to keep these people soil German magic
is impossible noise travels especially
at night even I can hear the trains run
along tracks over a mile away on an ask
me anything and I could also do an event
as far down as a swaying school on
summer night so so that there will be
beautiful disturbance is incorrect these
residents will have no rest from the
noise until late in the evening every
night of the week the light pollution
from the pitch Louis bow design to point
towards to pitch we're still go back to
glow to disturb both residents and night
wildlife since the initial plan other
methods have come to life they all said
vicinity and in July 2015 Jones shouts
agricultural and of study environmental
services babies concerns over these
taking that number of trees may be
affected by lead or access and that soon
tree preservation audio orders may be
affected by the layout he also had
concerned enroute protection areas of
these trees affecting both the health
and viability organ and on future works
due to the proximity to pitch and
lighting etc with regards to the
flooding issues a note in August 2015
from buildings and tech support
engineers who flying through proxy
district council plane office stated
that their observations for that service
water train which needs to be considered
to prevent issues to residential
properties at Bible close and Helen both
although it's why I Marquez parking for
120 cars there is no guarantee that the
local roads will not be used as
additional parking called the
inconvenience remain trying to park
after a long day at work that has now
been an article in the 10th world and it
made the evidence of these type of
pitches causing cancer although FIFA has
denied this more research needed to be
carried out in order to protect both the
players supporters and indeed the
residents who could potentially
breathing the dust from these pictures
which may contain arsenic mercury later
and Bentley other applications on this
site of being turned down due to
lighting issues so therefore as a town
council we feel this application should
be rejected by officers and the members
of this committee
yeah like you can slip
yeah Mr O'Hara sexy Jeff it's why my
school for the advocates you can also
pack for five minutes so that people
want me to go cool name Cameron really
want to present me go sunday forget
patient until very much about the need
and desire for this project also reads
like some of the perhaps minutes or so
for the work around it this one what's
always obviously got a very strong
reputation in the community for the
support tickets the young people then I
thought this is not just about a school
is about a community project raised very
fortunate and then has two outstanding
secondary schools without me speaking on
the other one just one of our school is
also one of the lowest funded schools in
the country per pupil we have continued
to maintain strong emphasis on quality
of self quality of teaching the high
standards we place on behavior by young
people and that means that were able to
continue to deliver excellent results
over time what it does mean is that
facilities in school are becoming tired
we know that people who come work for us
and the parents are coming around
appreciate nations or it is very much on
the spirit of how it works if you go and
look at many other schools in other
areas the armors affluent you will see
some fantastic Celesio years cup left
behind and that means that we're having
to work in operating way where we get
funding to benefit the young people they
deserve to have the facilities that
sitting there in other communities
massillon wisdom huge hope somebody
different words that we're going to work
very very hard to confirm that area in
actual fact for every pupil that we have
we get nearly sales and parents under
ESS average
beautiful in the school which works out
just SS averages who are about a million
1.3 million a year underfunded we were
very hard to very facilities to whether
the sorts of very benefiting young
people and this case would not
commercial venture we've been given
funding half a million rounds sorry if I
hundred thousand pounds to support this
process the company is time he benefits
we have them from opening for a longer
nicest are one that is supports local
youth groups and we are the commitment
to working with organized young groups
we know that there are concerns
expressed surround them something may
change so very much as a commitment to
the working with young people operate
for you should that should this not to
be approved in this case that funding
will be taking us where another
community that benefit from a funding
from our sport england and vs except ivy
so we're came to make the property to
that the higher costs that we have from
the times there will be used to replace
the pitch it has made your life cycle
and so the school is a non-profit at all
about of this process if you simply be
to replicate and provided as a legacy
for this facility for words and hence
the need for the balance of the hours
that you see in this palace if I also
understand the community's concerns I
wish I live very close for similar
facility myself as I can speak from some
degree of authority conservative culture
and we've spoken to other local entities
norpro similar facilities we have worked
with our partners to make sure that we
all of us actually requirements that
have come through and rubbing noise I
have seen obviously the scare stories
that have come out about help with these
facilities there are 20 to 30 times more
research rigorous research that shows
actually because of a deceivingly we
thought that for a moment we wouldn't be
standing here and presenting all in this
case and actually fact the top research
in the area says they use the same
standard for pictures if they use on
software for small children so we're
quite confident with in that respect the
drainage concerns that go on full advice
on the certificate actually it would
improve the condition never needed for
the students in this case if you look at
our pictures that old guitar bed bug
easily we are an acceptable weather as
it did in school hello I builds very
much upon ocean of the quality of stuff
if we were to continue to attract high
quality stuff we need to have not
outstanding facilities but decent
facility successful beyond reading
developing in this case really this is
an opportunity where we conclude to that
we've got partners with a brain just
thoughts hi opportunity for the other
people involved throughout the area and
supporting that we would give much more
useful students at the moment we're
having to avoid using fields have
damaged compensation
look at that it's a limiting access the
young people we got curriculum we
believe this specific an excellent
opportunity during the school day but
also for the young people are very
moving forward it's a community project
really use have a noise i t'ink drain
standards and health with metal base
should there be concern from local
residents overnight we will humans
loaded up later surveys so I'm going on
so the support breslin she has concerns
thank you just take it lightly third
seat is very daring on behalf of
Brisbane subjected to the occupation
seguro usefully to them it's really
something good for them thank you
Michael and officers have preempted me
we have the aerial photograph happy
handful and businesses and gem and
members I'm instructed by mr. Seaver
Davy and buy another of the local
residents who live in the immediate
vicinity of the occasion site and i'm
going to aggression with regard to
principally residential energy but also
with regard to I wanted to rather that
matters and I'll deal that there's
latter first and you followed of course
there's been a considerable range of
concerns express you've got a
comprehensive report before you which
covers a very wide range of matters
there's one particular aspect of that
range of matters that I'm like to do
this before I give the residential
which is the core matter than I want to
cover car parking it's unscientific but
only way to the meeting this evening i
did go into the car park at school just
to see what the situation was and as you
as local members will probably be very
little whereas it would give an activity
going on in the scored another school
car park even up to the six thirty seven
o'clock in the evening and i did count
33 cars in the front car part of the
school in the evening now that's the
base position tonight what it's rising
is that there isn't any detailed
analysis anywhere completely surprising
the mid- detailed analysis of the county
council as highway authority that's what
the impact will be on the car parking
demand we know their 120 car parking
spaces for men to the front car park and
the small miracle hard but we know that
there is quite considerable usage of the
car parking facilities at the moment
during the course of the evening and we
know that we are talking about
considerable increases in numbers of
users of the school facilities once this
facility is in place page 33 solid page
23 of the German axis statement there
could be 45 people on the pitch at a
time the changer the clear that we live
in 90 people in the vicinity the effect
of all of that taking realistic view of
car parking at r1 considering that as a
matter of brutality very few of those
people be using public trans
really speaks for itself so I would ask
you just bear that in mind there's a
deficiency here survivors car parking
analysis is concerned going to a
residential amenity of course members
this is a matter for your judgment you
often have to take this home object me
for the guard impact on existing living
conditions of residence obviously
residential amenities a criterion so far
as your own policy seal at CLT 10 is
concerned that's pointed out of the
officers report and also of course as
you will know paragraph 17 of the
National Party policy framework an
energy of course is a core Planning
principle to which parents should be
handed in making planning decisions and
it'll go to three facets of impact from
residential amenity character activity
and Tony character consider the existing
character of the area as it is adamant
an extensive green sward an ordinary
school playing field consider what is
composed now in terms of development
that will be coming film admittedly not
very great but there will be coming for
activity going on to form a more level
playing surface of course number the
artificial and a plane surface but in
addition of course as mr. strengths
motion it is very fair summary of the
report there will be both all stop
fencing and acoustic fencing the
acoustic element solid fence up to three
meters high or stop dancing 4.5 meters
in height but the knees and then of
course and you have the issue of the
lighting cons and second activity level
of activity now consider what that level
of activity is of course at present
while there are community activities in
evil of the school and of course is
limited the
use of the existing graph service
playing field of course is by the school
alone the essence of this perpetual ism
there will be a greatly increased level
of activity in other words there'll be
much much greater intensity of activity
that's got to be the caddy supplies of
course this proposal wouldn't make any
sense than the first place and then it
go to tiny well of course this is
already being bought out and what is
being said it's a very very particular
concern that even after consideration by
officers and see the proposed condition
nine that demanded Friday use of red
lighting 8am you tenderly my that their
patience today and then of course you
have a Saturday and Sunday evening usage
as well so in conclusion I ask you to
balance the considerations very
carefully of course it's desirable in
principle to enhance local sports
facilities me do you wanna use of school
facilities sizes i hope you are well and
solid and i'll ask you to include in
favor of the local residents object
really undecided i have visiting
walkouts staring to actually asleep now
that will not take part in the fact that
time for a night
Thank You German and some of the message
along the rain will be touched on signal
which regards its application for the 3g
picture floodlight image and the
relevant parties of the supporting this
application it does actually tie in with
with the hum work that I've been doing
on this well the 3g pitches is the
latest idea and then beautiful design
etc etc the facilities including a flood
lighting already outstrip where is
currently required or peers really quite
apart the facilities already in the
district khon songs I'm to an open
o'clock at night by mr. Friday's there's
hardly any activity during the day
during the evenings I'm told it could be
as busy as I t % but opt-ins lights are
switched off behind this is all that the
material consideration Saturday's are
literally interests on Saturday morning
set the op- no interest Sunday no take
up it's a similar situation of Rosie
Leisure Centre for going on your third
set take up during the week in the
evenings how many Saturday morning to
take up nothing in the other is nothing
on Sundays moving on to other
educational facilities Swain school does
have a 3g pitch but they don't have any
flood lights they could wake you up
there pitches out on saturday which is
used by youth for training and the
popular poppy club in the afternoons
during the season okay they are not
permitted to operate on a Sunday here
when school to GP they had flood
lighting they're permitted to operate
from 430 to 990 friday is well supported
there i prey on saturday Nigel six again
they are not permitted to operate on
Sundays need all these hours as
appearing club to the minimum 80-85 it
has the offices statement on page 22
available to justify the [ __ ] acting
and this is in my mind even with the air
pace compromised suggestion on ours
still in excess of 85,000 gem two years
ago as part of the rush with district
review of pitches dipping relation
football and other pitches with in the
ditch students a very sorry say sir that
we found that there was a marked decline
interesting activity in this area to
suction another you'll need rights what
was interesting again increasing girls
football thank you playing field which
is 150 yards from Fitz why miles school
since the early sixties has had four
pitches in use on set you up near sandy
moon subsequently Sunday afternoons the
youth football so this year there are no
requirements for any pitches and there
are not [ __ ] is needed pink in the park
looking on we also find the lack of
interest in as much as to the local news
have had two murders up in a district
itself in power combination a pact
emerged because of lack of interest
certain it seems to me if mr. Harris has
already said the regular one use up for
this is a funding stream moving up
further issues on the parking the figure
120 apartments flexes has been quoted
I've counted in each set of 85 42 normal
days during though this is just people
operate out of the school this evening i
can assure mr. Daggett send the club all
the car parking spaces were gone and the
roads were approved off in the
surrounding areas all the surrounding
here is had partial or will have partial
parking restrictions on the during the
day he'll one of the other areas that's
been highlighted you know what I'm kind
looking on
the noise I'll take lobsters comments
regarding sunday morning taking an hour
later what's the special about an hour
later on Sunday morning show you that
apply to all outside the day lighting a
similar situation in every port on page
11 highlights the viability is unequally
on the acceptable if they are expended
so I would suggest that this application
is turned down for three reasons the
parking plan scheduled is not submitted
take into account detector increase in
traffic and parking needs and the
potential lighting pollution for these
extended out operation and its impact is
far in excess of what residential
reasonably expect a little have to live
with in the semi urban residential area
and going the potential noise nuisance
from these extended else for gays in
excess what business should reasonably
expect when moving in a semi-rural
residential area let me get some so I
said okay I believe that other
indications of absolute menace mission
to see as walkouts also gets the heater
should address that by a pencil set up
yes if you can understand that I only
had five minutes I will be quick quips i
can let me refer you mr. chairman to the
issues of loss of residential amenity to
neighboring properties through noise and
light illumination in my view not
reasonably acceptable or foreseeable in
a residential area in the middle of
which is having to be parachuted in
artificial pitch with 50 meters
floodlights open for trade from 800
hours to 2200 hours monday-friday 800
hours to 20 hundred hours saturday and
saturdays and sorry honey hey
and sundays and bank holidays
illuminations gem from the flood lights
and noise are intertwined what involves
the other there's been a plethora of
objections to this application 119 total
addresses in 30 local roads mr. chairman
the site is surrounded by residences a
paragraph 3 31 says the rear elevation
of the closest neighbor is 58 meters
from the floodlights only a critic
features about 21 meters you can imagine
the noise of the illumination of trying
to settle an infant down to sleep 8 40
40 first were complaining with the
disabled son sensitive to noise tonight
was difficulty sleeping on page 47 a
complainant Safety's rear house what is
7 meters from the bank I think this is
the same what is referred to as a
detective Fuhrman's and that megan so
she's boundary is only 51 meters away
from this is going on to 10pm under
surprise egg games and this and sundays
and bank colleges certain days a week 52
weeks in here mrs. share knowledge and
illumination will cause a not a convener
to there will be an unacceptable noise
and illumination to the surrounding
residents during hours of dark is when
the fight is not our an operation where
young children are getting ready for bed
or doing their homework this is the time
when residents are resting after tools
and tribulations of the day and can
resubmit very quiet they are in close
proximity to the pitch and in mind you
cannot reasonably be expected to put up
with that level of noise and a
nation from players and spectators which
is not reasonably foreseeable in a
residential area 20 living next to a
school what does president say like
there's lots of residential immediately
on 27 the march two thousand five this
case were a few swaying parts for
permission from a widow playing [ __ ]
you appreciate mr. chairman that this
saw as opposed to Fitz why Marcus out in
the middle of a residential area on
appeal day to the third January 2006 the
pitch was allowed with no artificial
lighting proposed even with hardly any
surrounding residences inspector saw the
wisdom in regulating artificial lighting
and stipulated that no artificial
lighting should be installed without the
consent of the lobster district council
paragraph 3 37 states in 1994 Planning
Commission was refused for 18 x 16
bigger meet floodlights in connection
with nor whether grass pitcher fits why
not it was refused because the level of
illumination to the site by reason of
its location scale and intended hours of
operation would be detrimental to the
amenity currently enjoy by local
residents immediately surrounding the
side and this is a run goes on to say
and I think this is welfare well written
moreover the illumination of the site
would allow you to the site past the
times that would normally be expected
then I created therefore creating
increased disturbance rejoin occupied
that is the situation now paragraph 3 38
states there wasn't a large appeal
concerning the use of your way the pitch
which was allowed but again inspector
saw fit to impose a condition preventing
lighting in 2004 and all they the quick
way
it was approved and a subsequent
conditioning pose preventing by
believers wonders I've had my five
minutes no wonder the motorcycle
training in paragraph 3 39 estates
proposed pitch has the potential to
affect a greater number of people to the
90 94 2004 application due to is more
central system the 99 for applications
for pizza southern boundary at this time
to zone oatmeal feel close the two
thousand five containers for netball
courts a northern value and the new jump
there is a northeastern quarter profile
340s argues with respect is Australia
interpretation it erroneously argues the
problem is ebonylife spillage the
problem as inspectors noted i
appreciated is light illumination which
will cause a loss of residential dignity
and noise pass the times that would
normally be expected very briefly there
is a parking issue can locally the money
bought from everything equal and produce
pages in the two teams and spectators
Fitz why Mike responses and activism
tech items is in the evenings there may
not be a parking facilities they not
popular town it's too far fairview park
thank you wise up netflix has enemies
are close in between 7pm knowing they
will park in the rows which will cause
obstruction and possible danger they
know clothing
as I said Tony also had five minutes
i'll give you my god there are a few
technical questions if I may tell I will
ask the flood lighting and by my
calculation 15 meters that's something
the reason of 45 to 47 fix thing that's
correct can I have that in comparison to
the height of the surrounding trees and
we have a more technical information
that this for what the light on the top
of the polls will be what type of
lighting and how that will be this
societies they said some things you have
to end your purchase from chennai my
grand opening with the excellent
lighting but I don't have a figure for
the license of treason sorry sir generic
iPad jejeje oxygen gas to walk [ __ ]
like these on Hannibal the lighting
society in the report at 3.31 it says
proposing or 888 provides around the ATP
on colors references in my pajamas oh yo
yo cubicles a description they should
probably on the policy powder-coated
grown-up life there will be two light
fittings of each column the averages
agreement is to move looks and puppets
to the image and us within a minimum of
warranty looks that's awesome great
unpublished looks or playing a more
professional purposes so much most of
the occupation BTW 107 drug dealer like
nice impact statement submitted as
providing execute on thin lines glare
about religion light the lighting
impacts take advice the lights that is
dissipates 22 looks then faiza meters of
heads like it's Porter it also explains
that all light confirmations we had to
take a meeting and open untouched sites
and the valleys noticeable would be
further reduced by any existing trees
adjacent buildings or natural swing
assessment provides a visual salford
lighting of the pitches undecided 50
meters pound 60 metres away which is
similar to the current scenario with an
ear infection closest would be 58 meters
from the floodlights intended operating
line horizontally so they see less
diplomatic if I may cover generally I
would shoot me that it's unlikely
beginning with the height of the poles
of the trees themselves are going to do
much in the way to screen each 20
kilometer thought they were everywhere
sunlight but the mature tree wouldn't
probably meet you probably a mature
trees and what retype it to me about 35
40 meters
catch the legislation
Thank You mr. chairman when I first read
through this report very first powder
and the material considerations caught
my eye so things we're not to being
clarified and perhaps you can correct me
if I'm wrong but it says and I will read
it out the application is supported by
need statements and as councillor the
mall calstrs very has pointed out it is
not understood if the motive assessment
included it's very lame chemist or or
regulator centers I'm assuming that it
hasn't now as it so happens I live very
close to colors for plankton to feel
suppose it happens so not that for
certainly not as closest the residents
here would be to this pitch we have
disturbance noise on a football pitch it
is an essentially ignored but then we
are not to phils away however it is
acceptable because over the years it has
diminished because as the broad house
has quoted out the use of the pages sees
them to be so intensive is also sexual
because it ceases and when it gets done
I cannot see that it is reasonable to
expect this level activity that is
proposed on the annals that are proposed
the residential floor amenity for most
residents will be severely compromised
in my beer and when that might appear
it's unacceptable the festivities here
one is the use of a football pitch which
I don't think is probably an
unacceptable use of that but the
lighting takes it into a different realm
and compromises the residential energy
because not only will
the residence but some of the resultant
noise into the late hours of the night
and it will be 24 7 which is
understandable Thank You mr. Chaney
thank you cancel mrs. Henson
thank you do what no one seems to a
technique to consideration is the hiding
route maybe in the winter those trees
are deciduous trees they will not [ __ ]
up any one thing at all the cancellation
danger I was that he upset that I
understand we can desire in the school
and it's walking community or more
additional perhaps more convenience or
issues but same time I understand that
there's been a hundred nineteen
objections from members of the public on
a residential amazing and that's
something I want to ignore when making a
bad decision under the table planning
considerations as mr. day said we'd is a
matter of judgment and my judgment is to
Paul out quite so much rather heard the
semen in terms of the hours of use Tim
p.m. i think is too late the reason it's
too late is because it's ted bearded not
9pm la tía but at the same time that is
not when the users of the facility
Ashley depart the area they won't depart
the area for at least another hour and I
think that then goes far against an
acceptable residential amazing and
expectation in terms of the audio our
officer actually said it will cause
moderate annoyance well I think
moderates Alliance is something i have
this at idle hands down what resinize
Alliance at all and this council is
advice and said forbidding their turn at
all I
show you hide from the findings in the
early days of living in that area or the
very bad language that seems to come
from idle to new football Pacific
weekends but I was also expecting
evening with it slowly and you're quite
as we've been told there's nothing you
can do about it so I don't have any
great faith in any self policing by the
school of youth activity in the evening
or more particularly adult activity in
terms of parking and I don't think it's
sufficient either and I can't see users
walking from the town center parking to
the site and more particularly i can
actually see the council having to
consider residential permit parking in
all of the adjoining roads and that in
the wall cause more trouble for the
residents and this facility I can't see
that they have a sensibles set of big
book of good bed colors at all on
balance I find that the residential
community is a reason for a refusal
channel thank you
if you notice Cristiano Tori I am being
able to see in there where it indicates
who would be administering the use of
this proposed picture there will be
outside school hours we neither school
for maybe somebody else's will actually
will be controlling use it I don't
believe this response confirm the scenes
at monthly the school's I cyrusi mostly
but for example physical and
opportunities you have any further
issues having it cancel cancel room me
too I mean most of the points are always
would bring up already been brought up
but so just one other thing aren't
familiar with you've got most of us
familiar with the area and are made
representations made for me to be fair
about concerns but I have knowledge of
the road around the area and we are
aware that there are parking issues
already and I'll be looked at whatever's
handy Council for some for isn't it
bulky but that road 10 in a row he's
becoming a country because of the issues
of it for the traffic it becoming a
comfort for many people from hopefully
road through to East without or anywhere
else of that song and we're talking
about evening enjoy me
in real terms and most of the people
would be coming home from work which
will add to the party because they will
be barking outside air crises it's
already a trial to get through that road
and anymore if we're the people come out
from down there your chosen of wherever
they've been especially weekends that
both Leno vicinities now I'm seeing it
when there's been different occasions of
the scope with parastatal children and I
can't there and I popped anywhere and
we've is a shirt on this road and I
think mrs. Trent if I called you
correctly you might have pushed swing
about everybody said he would you keep
discussing this with the EUC traffic
management did okay that right or wrong
something along those lines where you
were talking about looking at tracking
boat there hasn't been assessed yet not
come up to simply if I might come back
sure i was reading what we decline a
late night so that came in afterwards of
view of a resident that came in where
they said they would be they've
mentioned working about clothes and
responsibilities secc wasn't part of my
presentations at the end of my
presentation where because they letter
arrived after we would prepare the
addendum a prize to read it to you in
for some private room it's just that i
would have funds a lot of these issues
should have been addressed before
wording application be made so we could
I have a better idea what circumstances
are and it's changed a little bit that
we seem to be worrying more about trees
and we are about our residents
Thank You counsel are there any other
members wishing to sleep inside I've not
heard a motion proposed or second it is
yet are they in nervous and wish to do
so
Satan mr. Chairman I propose refusal if
you know you second it first that's
reality thank you is known we will need
to we will need your recently okay it
plant-eaters this development would
reduce a level of illumination and noise
not reasonably acceptable or foreseeable
to the surrounding residents and a
corresponding loss with immunity it will
also be for parking over spilled into
the nearby roads causing congestion and
risk
I'm salons your answer it how much only
we can just take miss kaswell's down
just check that happen is worth the I've
got concerns about raising a patient
parking parking standards documents
advises the fact that parking for
outdoor pitches should be 20 car parking
spaces plus 1 pinterest spectator seat
which there aren't any in this case if
we use a parkings reason refusal that
would not be substantiated by casual
hunting so reasons we can look at and
the grounds for refusal would be a
visual amenity for not being around all
these and delighting to initiate new
race okay well I mean in no
circumstances would you like to take
Mike's my first sentence in to this
developer confused 11 illumination a
noise not recently said no foreseeable
disraeli residence and the corresponding
loss honey
and defeat the other point is that I've
been reminded by on conservation but
them in our view partly hasn't been
properly assess from from the quality of
the parking standards as I'm gonna stick
that in fact which only comes initiate
anything because they're not enough in
all turned violent it requires requires
25 car parking spaces because once i
attain rotators from up on it
immediately going to know if you don't
recommend refusal or to make sure we've
got reeses refusal that could be studied
it on appeal time from the house point
of view and brutal an obvious point of
view and there is a panic he is very
much a case we can make it looking at
like three numbers on to the point of us
to make an argument for group primarily
based for noise and lighting I think are
important too
disassociate it we have from the density
property search by assessed by six
highway Samina for the convenience going
almost all of those crimes you little
more safe to visit all these sightings I
later I would remind you what the other
biases the highway authority for
discounted healthy experts in assessing
such weapons okay right look better
let's just stick to the young the level
of the new nation and noise but level of
illumination or what it takes into
account the excessive hours as well i
think that's that's implied in its I
don't think what has been specifically
mentioned I mean the only presidential
NT the artificial pitch to generate
additional activity within the school
playing field making evening so that we
can because in close proximity
neighboring properties that's around the
school playing field to traditional
activities this represents an
exceptional noise disturbance as
enjoyment reasonably expected by the
occupiers of our properties that
surround the place or playing field with
the properties at brandons God Nerys
country to paraná relaxed knowing
topology am one of the current
management plan 2014 an additional
reason around lighting the flame
lighting to the artificial could be used
later in the evening
generate mexico micronesia neighboring
properties surrounding the school
playing fields I wanna go to Jersey and
5 2014 guess I because you so the
microphone please take this cancel our
second engagement of person if I may put
a chance expand again and personally I
would be very sad to see facility and
funding for it lost from this district
and Carlos way as a result I wonder
whether counselors were to the committee
would be interested in amending hours of
use if at all so was tired too
I've seen shakeys ahead so forget only
to mention it I do to say that we we
cannot provide or take advantage of your
first funding which is offered by by
others we'll go over everything and make
a skilled getting there is no support
for suction amendment will go to a vote
on the proposal form of refusal on the
reasons so given the shadow show bands
for those in favor of refusal
but against quite conclusively carried
the puzzle isn't fuse so thank you guys
do look awesome i get around of course
you are very welcome to stay for two
further items and usually would you can
shut down from everybody
Oh
this is
I
details
t
zero minus 20
public if you wish to be in qamishli so
that we busted alternating it's a really
sorry
Oh
Thank You varies settle down please we
will now move to agenda item set
entities veins the rear championship
relay tortured then crystallized will
present the aggravation for us is a
hybrid application or a politician or
reserves most resolved with all my cash
reserve Department access inside the
provision of a rugby club soda pictures
of facilities for details of their
prospective job and the pitches the
African obviously its own is 10 with
unlimited site before us and red outline
is the site of interest it relates to
the relocation of West Africa up to this
part the site to facilitate the ant the
new the development of the large area of
the gap which are necessary here or
industrial uses the current pictures and
actresses here and basically is being
relocated to this position here the
application is the split away from the
main application to a manifold the new
pictures we put in place for to ensure
that the pic with the Oba Koko moved
within good time to work the development
to occur under aquaculture into your
project this is the site of Florence and
the shows and probably is mainly
Winfield
you've got the review is here you've got
your brick work site is down here and
obviously going up the road between here
okay you've got the council's to push
off to the side this is the action um
it's specifically outline of shipping
and cooler for you next month is there
the new industrial that industrial park
and this is the location of the pitches
this is going to be a perfect pitch and
this will be fun little pitch and the
remaining pictures will just be normal
[ __ ] the science it's been for its
own one the top names in phone three the
works I proposing on site will ensure
that there's no greater impact on on on
the flooding and obviously the
attenuation that will flow into the into
the new works undertaking for the
industry of sight obviously the details
about to come into in terms of the
layout landscaping and sound design of
the clubhouse obviously is emitted as
Lena preserve mutters but the option
site is removed in the greenbelt and
this is the proposed location of the new
clubhouse in parking it's obviously in
quite close proximity to this to this
from the new industrial estate and what
that mean is that the building's even
though they would be technically what
was greenfield one of a seed form part
of this whole area here access to the
site and beer along here and through the
industrial estates and then on through
the new spine that
ratings part we develop meat obviously
and this development obviously accords
with the the [ __ ] obviously sitting and
did they it obviously called with our
policy env2 which allocates aside from
relocated overcoming pitches the site is
opposite of a cultural interests and our
conditions recommended to deal with that
issue the site obviously isn't currently
got any particular ecological importance
but they're also concerned we lost a
buncha steps which is shown with a
location of that is the badges that is
is in this location around here what
major centers here and i was there are
some other issues in to go to a better
life and anna normal activity that you
have in discipline area so that would be
dealt with my condition as well and
obviously the other considerations are
was a foot part that runs on the side of
the site this is that I have no further
obstructions local pub obviously the
problem is infiltrating wall which the
most programmers area any surface water
recovery in the compact and the parking
will be absurd cheap achieve a warning
one yeah refill great obviously
obviously being a betterment for that
site the Denari pattern existing trees
I'm only to the pictures of you said are
going to be funny later or 230 test we
find people that with my condition to
fly on to themselves the restaurant
lighting
moments the nearest essential properties
are some 250 meters away there was no
greater traffic movements because we
just relocated existing I'm at smokey
[ __ ] proposed speaker access to the site
is acceptable the pulping standard for
this site based on 200 spaces however
this is unlike for like replaces not too
many developments in fact that we're not
rooting a completely from you use here
and the there is 81 worse places
proposed plus requirements my condition
provided is overflowing 56 parking
spaces there's been some commentary in
the paper today about this site to do
the fact that its close proximity to a
major hazard hazard site this relates
the old brickworks and it's not existing
usually to be under here anything else
and deserting obviously whatever
incisions make this may turn items if
it's money to approve it then obviously
they can be referred to the Secretary of
State or for them to make any further
considerations why you see we recommend
an approval subject to conditions that
are such that in operating report
obviously unrepresentative statement
thank you topics e ain't government this
item
you have the follicle one years ago
thank you Jeff Allen I don't miss to
retrain findings of your officers report
for cleaning the welcome the office of
recommendation and permissions royalty
an indication of the existing recipe but
without facilities this application
represents the first stage in delivering
the wider aspirations with the Jordan
area action plan which would include the
development of circa nine thousand
square meters of b1 b2 business arm
which represents significant investment
and investor confidence in the area I
could support a twenty-five percent
growth in employment within boxford over
the next 15 years the business park is
set is subject to a separate application
which is already be pointed out should
we before you on the seventeenth of
March the application before you see in
seeks the land use principle of a
relocated rugby cup in accordance with
your own adopted whatever action plan
and has evolved following discussions
with not only your officers with
presentations to number of viewers
members but also Essex County highways
self in Borough Council the Rugby
Football Union Sport England and above
the club themselves once the design of
the cloud still to be agreed the peach
layout of fixes the location of the
clubhouse and car parks which is a
rewarding mentioned will actually
provide a like-for-like replacement
which again is required by policy the
[ __ ] themselves have been subject to
an independent economists report to
ensure that the reprovision represents
at least a like-for-like replacement
again as required by your own policies
the sighting of the development which is
not to be pointed out adjacent to the
southern boundary of the science seeks
to limit any harm to the openness of the
Greenbelt an intention is to relocate
your rugby club in time for the
on the 17 both 2018 season and to allow
the development the business partner or
to come forward fall 2017 the granting
of this application for their poor
facilitator in conclusion the
application accords with watchman's
development plan and the explorations of
the National Planning Policy program and
other prospectively asked that is a
quote paycheck thank you government I
see new war would make this person I see
one not made by President you take
personal phone I'm emergencies reserved
okay thank you in that case cancel this
will catch the basin cancel it probably
also laughter that and then Castle mrs.
Mason will never do this indication 90s
okay Kathy basin hm they can I start by
saying I welcome the development of the
the business part and in particular it
fits with the determination of our own
business plans having recently put in
place and I'm a little confused and
concerned about this reference rather
help the safety executive so you should
refuse this application now we're not
making light of it but I don't quite
understand why they make a particular
point if we feel that it's anonymous and
it will be referred to the Secretary of
State can I can be sure the assistant
director of planning you're saying that
this will be definitely preferred to
sector is safe that's what's in the
slide or are we saying that it is in the
discretion of the health and safety
executive
to do so or not now I need clarification
of that because I don't understand I
actually young because I'm about this
Katie perspective in his adventures that
are taken ill Sutton inside did a bit of
work on that point because I needed some
clarification on that don't you read you
out of the HSE and the clock on this
point it says like other strategy
consulting HSCs role in Angie's planet
is advisory there's no power to refuse
consent or planning or upon application
it is a responsible of the HSA or the PA
to make a decision regarding and so when
local needs and benefits and other
planning considerations on all side hsd
advice in which day they should give a
technic give HSE advice ellipses of
intentions time authorities may need and
maybe like to grow up animation against
HTC device in such cases even opportu
the mother further as long as the final
authority understands an insensitive
reasons for all that advice however the
HSE has the option it released for
example that the risks are sufficiently
high to request the decision is called
in for consideration by the Secretary of
State in England and Wales that's a very
rare situation I'm so basically and the
vision before them to call this in so
what what happens is that like
everything now like we have to go we put
this information into an interest a
system that HSE providers and that gives
us the indication of whether it's high
or low risk and because of watch was
sword next door at the brickworks this
site because of its close proximity has
come out as a high as a narrative the
high risk so as far as we're concerned
planning a play decision make some
advice given to us by the HSE that there
is no that we've made that decision the
agency now can make a decision to call
it in and it's up to that about that
decision Jeremih terrifies it perfectly
thank you that's a couple general that
we gonna have the points already money
as far as the one I wanted to raise
concerns because one of that carrot
place until I wasn't the example over on
that so that that's fine as far as I can
so just to say I think this is the first
saw application we considered around
apartments of enormous we all knew that
we need to displace the Rugby Club other
than need a new barriers to operating so
I think that was a worldview beforehand
now this would seem to be timely
application because I know that pitchers
needs some time to actually prepare get
forget to drone et cetera so that they
can come forward so from that point of
view I think it's working as far as the
attribute versus animal short it's very
clear to how is that the brickworks
haven't been used for some time so I
think he's probably set for 20 years now
like that so you know in that respect
I'm you know learning money with some
pollution they're always use some
pollution then you know even people like
the cold finding of art without
pollution but it's being on that
an apology but having said that I think
who was like Silas link that back
picture okay what should the situation
Thank You mr. chairman to you at this
verification to quite switch on to the
assistant director can provide the
information I require under clapping
saying the object at hawk extended
States a maximum [ __ ] loss provision
they of 204 equate to 200 further on in
the record it says that this
collaboratively 300 at peak times I
understand that this is a like-for-like
however do you have a minimum parking
standard provision and that's not
covered in the report and if so is it
met that's the first point when that's
terrified off her phone back the second
thing it's a maximum of requirement and
as far as written servants application
would be like for like provision so the
expected use would be like for like what
those are currently moment the levels of
300 and actually I know coming from the
rugby situation it was when my children
they broke these situations at 300 other
peaks and they are not all the time they
are random we friends during the year
when it which is that figure we have
raising issues with the parking at some
of us of additional cross street parking
to provide some additional parking on
site to hopefully alleviate some of a
over store parking that will happen
during those a click and most peak times
which tend to be sunday morning clean
box of Junior fee and saturday mornings
when
the sort of hopes and senior at we play
thank you that the question hasn't been
answered I asked is there a minimum of
envision is it yes or no is that in
terms of this site it's a minimum it's a
maximum requires either a minimal was
only one sandwich there's nothing and
thank you that's four times after Peggy
and it the other and queries just a
small one the recert matters will they
be thrown back to committee
we have live application when it came in
and went for an exhibition at Point do
the same food you're just going to say
in that case can it come back to
committee thank you but it seems your
militia definitely I mean no fitness and
we primary election is a 32gb heh just
quitting with God to thee How safety
safety a few digits a new thing that's
come out because I don't recall this
coming up as an issue for the slight in
sunny which is annoying because s is
operative far more documents no one
turned on it did come up through the
animals that the holler at the heck
agency have changed the way they deliver
although I'm Louis risen and it was
brought up the cast mate which movie to
start styling site and has Beckinsale's
has been through that to that process as
well the issue of this side relates to
the brickworks because them song is very
much consent to sell something on that
site and they can sense for me and it's
not through the parents it's a hazardous
waste storage and that's what that
permission still is live on that consign
or a sudden therefore is an area that
you have a there's an a radius draw
around that hazardous site and it has
it's like then cause issues as in this
all we've got a great work presents or
hazardous fun
solid and therefore this is all into
that that make sense you see I've not a
proposal to approve the recommendation
of solids yet Photoshop so if i move
that I'll save ya proposed five casa cut
your own safety by a castle made
reservation right in that case i ask for
a vote on the lesson in the other masses
which now rise in for the ending in here
that proposal okay no move to open those
in favor of the offices recommendation
to approve please indicate it seems the
members thank you
yeah because she's accrued we never to
like the place
so
right it's 45 high street modi essex
proposed replacement faces on the
internet the strengths of the littlies
attaching the application will see all
the springs the eastern side of brady
ice cream and it'll here and this is the
junction of betting like the high screen
comes up to where we are in the church
on top here this is midway down your
primary shopping frontage in a better
picture looking across the street worth
noting for the recommendation chairman
is that what i refer to an
administrative approval of its time
architecture concrete brick and subject
tonight is this union over here which is
in the middle of the two-story buildings
to the back which has i built out
overhang under which signage which
concerns us tonight exists here is the
existing signage you'll see it's a
simple lettering loner above the main
entrance in a typical place show one of
the figure worth noting Chairman's is
overhanging the bill
just referring to the long shot if we
look at the proposal this is a similar
wording and lettering but with the
inclusion of a low blow I think it's
referred to the glastonbury top or
something vomit federal authority that
you'll see that it's the same basic
letter format which is the inclusion of
the logo and it's internally illuminated
chairman now it's public corporate style
and that we see from time to time as
companies rebrand change their image to
reflect the way they move forward the
new face ship would be finishing our
meeting with these letters in razor
critic like the existing one now to just
take you back though it's now replace
the policies set 10 to your previous
local plan that was superseded in 24
taking deep take a clear stance on it
suddenly ruminated facial science the
positive is now in place your DM 30 owns
is it softer approach which looks at
internally illuminated or rather
projecting phase your size of the
emphasis on rejecting and officers
abilities are slightly ambiguous either'
not so clear as practice at 10 used to
be and you'll see that the county's
efficient adviser and rayleigh town
council both object to the internal
illumination and it's not
characteristics are very conservation
area but your secret officers assessment
the policy when our work takes us to the
character and appearance of the existing
building and those around which is why
are labeled on the appearance of the
buildings this is attached to in the
opening photographs you'll see that
officers consider that there would be
very limited material harm in this case
disagreeing with our colleagues and that
County because really only difference
between two schemes is the logo that you
see the lettering is very similar so the
measure of harm between what you have
existing if you to refute this
application existing signage no doubt
would stay and as if you approve it or
you will get these two changing color
which isn't before us but the inclusion
of the logo and officers consider when
you look at the architecture of the
existing building and the Navy and one
that is attached to his case officers
recommend that permission should be
granted any Jeff thank you there are
other public speakers but C capsule book
ways and all them both Leslie wishes to
see then we will go to kitchen endless
doing that and we should speak of it
again various the catalogs and indicated
any others of the loan place gets along
with lots of that wall Castle ocean
place maybe German the pub I speak like
no I think much of an egg egg kind of
sticking to the rules when it comes
please I'm only the initial side and mr.
spanks were putting out their policies
at 10 find out against this sort of
thing and as rumors we haven't been yet
acquainted with the new overalls bookish
he says I'm softer so I had to defer to
him on that one I must say it was
consider ourselves very lucky that we
even got playing out
action because generally speaking in the
High Street the businesses do this I
nice and you change their functions and
fantasies with all the recipe without
being bothered with pain applications so
having listened to this for strengths
I'm afraid that in this case I must say
I must agree perhaps we should say okay
go ahead do it he gets along thank you
sorry to hear that the reason I sorta
focus better was exactly on this issue a
variety we have a conservation area
agreement and to refer to an old whether
under thought you know they made it to
get built in his unfair because in
languages that would be part of the
conservation way the thing is though the
region here which is about something Ivo
about setting there we go to do 30 I on
page 8 12 item 33 see specifically
sightings of important thing I thought
about the receptor the carriage of the
building which thy sake and surrounding
areas and also an advert do not
including prominent naturally flights
and symbols material color of facial
spray winter stupid papers on that
but in our item 2 says eternity
illuminating rather project size
promised studies them later on so
basically it's something that we should
look at this very carefully now I what
considerations of this are quite simple
there was a planning application put
into this select another company there I
could be correct if I'm wrong and this
was in 1997 which I was given a copy by
offices and I having to you and on the
second on the first page item two this
is the maximum movements of the
advertising if i permitted to be display
shall not exceed a maximum luminous of
two country bored to death and sedo
numbers in this candle whatever well
this one's going to be 350 that's almost
twice as bright so there's an issue
about the luminance if you like and how
that will stand out is current site so
if you added nearly quickly they also
talks on to this previous application at
the sign was neat to form the halo this
is internally illuminated signs so
actually illuminate a wording so i think
there's a difference you know that we
must understand it but more importantly
in all this and this did not just the
only side if we start letting one or two
people drift away for their conservation
thing before we go there we are whole
towns can be speckled with different
ideas and and as mr. I've already body
there are people in the temperament a
lot because it is it you know without
any control so I have decided that
target I just think it says on you no
reference to the pilots or bad thing
according to
report so in my opinion which is of the
intestines Buddhist the opposite opinion
I think it's incorrect an odd about the
striation I recorded through policy but
p.m. 39 so for that reason I allowed to
destroy the ventilation lots of you
should construe HD and the preamble
which is part of policy during 38 and
this year 38 is my business affecting
conservation areas on this buildings and
it says advertisements will be permitted
on listed buildings in appropriate
circumstances whether it cannot be
demonstrated that the airburst harmed
their commercial structure the building
would love it would not result but
permitted we're committed on listed
buildings and conservation areas
advertisement should adhere to policy DM
37 is that money but and should be
sensitive to the character of the
earlier visually unobtrusive unobtrusive
us appointment and mr strannix made
about community and underneath the
canopy vision of juicy well-designed
relocated and should not create account
access issues in terms of the what we've
got there at the moment and where I'm
going to it as here to the the aims of
OCD m38 should do fine just like my next
hopper to Jerry food and I refer to the
edge very likely the EC start
conservation and he says I do not have
consumed with the desire to renew the
Saudi principle I've got that excuse all
I have concerns over the proposed
internally illuminated fascia songs
which I do not they will be accessible
to conservation area in turn in the road
runs right now and the info body this
would be a nice be an alien a pretty
permanent s up of a really believe that
a proposal new phone you side with other
detrimental which not preserve enhanced
conservation error I will never be
supportive or but none so we're not are
between against our sorry it's this at
least the illumination of the issue and
it's the balance of the conversational
conservation areas of risk that's where
do your shoes and I continue to side of
the conservation officer fo make sense
I've gone back to conservation Iran step
unknown ethnicity and I got some flavor
device from the confessional officer and
what he got back to me said is the
proliferation internally later side is
something I think we should try to
resist it is the case of trying to limit
the amount of what's already existing
fence wonderful however having rectal
having married what you've said in
making those into those colors on board
I think it'll be hard our view the
building currently makes a positive
contribution conservation area and I
suspect an inspector may take the view
that the increase in terminal native
signage would not have a greater impact
on the character in terms of
conservation than already is evident and
research unlike our light resist it but
I suspension
action is that if all we have to we have
to deal with mr. Chen is just one other
couple members of adventures about
businesses changing their signage per se
as if messages bear in mind that in
aphasia you can change your signage
without meaning adverb consents only
when it's illuminated in the fascia so
it's quite possible that some companies
that are going on favorite emotion they
might change the signage from time to
time it's not donated and it wouldn't
comfortable men's 13 stripes then any
other gasps oh so true nature oh just
great for all of the current site is the
lumen ok see ya how therefore the only
reason is before us as the planning
matters because if liter- animated it
was externally eliminated it wouldn't be
a plan consideration or correct and
therefore if we look business was to
change its name I had a larger name we
wouldn't need to cut before us so
actually operate
I just has a couple all right put you
out Waka little gem just to say I think
people of the wording that's actually up
there now I think that [ __ ] takes my
view internally illuminated literary
plus immodest edition of logo and I
think that's how I should consider it
Jim is a modest addition to what's
already there I think you know anybody
walking pulse instrument even notice it
frankly but it's obviously a corporate
you know seniors here if you like for
clarks and that's why I was doing it
much as I love toward ization serving up
short many of us who else is in branding
but would know about that sort of doubt
that I don't think it's really going to
change in whose life I think as far as
that's concerned you know it sir I think
that you know in training are we we are
told about when you have a planning
application it's about the either impact
it has a particular thing I think the in
tactics is virtually new so they are be
quite a big party money it's gonna plotz
actually as you say putting an
applicator / at all because if they
change the sign in a different way they
could've just done it then I'll take the
points already at night thank you Jim
thank you guys come on guess the little
missus little games I think you
generally yeah we should allow this to
go through it's very minor nothing
offense
put it all in a cup people probably
won't even notice it's definitely she
totally fair thing again but SOS is
everybody so good unless there is a very
key point which you wish to rise briefly
in my five minutes chem if every just
three feet every situation about
changing Asia's I would be I was
referred to some of these national
operations mainly agarra changing their
shop France and various other things
without any question thank you can
certain people I sixpence which is that
a little surprise that these particular
buildings are in fact in a conservation
area of the interested in hearing one
sir someone Livesey look at the Prince
Charles like to that same happen but
there we are that's not another time do
we have a proposal for motion to prove
that's a set time going to sit now
essence of lupins with those in favor of
the pretty ball please show
I think that is the carry for the motion
is approved on the approbation approved
for you discover those having a license